foreign
people see optimism as kind of a
temperament Sunny View and I think there
is some of that and I have a natural
amount of it but over time I've actually
become even more optimistic than my
general tendency deliberately it's kind
of like a learned optimism and I think
the reason we should be as optimistic as
we can is because
it is how we make really good
things good complicated things so it's
hard enough
well I mean it's very hard to make good
complicated things work because
generally there's more ways things can
fail than they can succeed and
it's very unlikely that we're going to
make
something really good that's complicated
inadvertently
they're hard to do so we have to
kind of see it and believe that it can
be done and that is where the optimism
comes in is envisioning something and
then believing that you could make it
real
because when we look back on history and
that's where a lot of my optimism comes
we realize that most of the things that
we have
now have been made by people who are
optimistic Ally viewing that there was
possible to make them and believe that
they were going to make them and could
imagine them so I think of it as a work
of imagination where you kind of Imagine
a good scenario
which is harder to do than imagining a
scenario where it fails or collapses it
is much easier to imagine how things
break
than it is to see how they work
and that's why entrepreneurs and all the
others are rightly lauded because
they're going against that grain it's it
is hard to imagine how we could have
this thing that seems like it is
improbable and most things that work are
improbable that's the definition from
the Santa Fe complexity theory is that
things breaking down is the probable
complicated things working are
improbable by definition and so you're
against the improbable and that work of
Imagining the improbable and having the
improbable
succeed
in believing it can is optimism which
means that the optimists are the ones
who shape our future so I'd like to give
a little story of a car
and you need to have brakes on the car
to steer the car yeah
I'm with you so far
but the engine is actually the more
important element and so there are
people and our there are organizations
and there are methods that are going to
be doing the braking
and I think they're essential I want
breaks in the car but I just feel that
the break can overwhelm and cause
stagnation in that we also want to
remember to focus on making the engine
even stronger
so I emphasized the engine
so I want to take a closer look at the
engine so if things breaking down are
the probable and there are many more
ways things can go wrong then they can
go right right
if I'm hearing you correctly
and maybe also bringing in some of my
own
position it would be that active
optimism is probably more valuable than
passive optimism
the belief that you can make things turn
out all right as opposed to the belief
that things will turn out all right and
therefore
I can go about my day and not concern
myself with worries about ABCD e all the
way through Z and I'm curious if you
suddenly had the
Kevin Kelly Institute for
active optimists
how you would cultivate this or
maybe encourage it in more people
because I do see
optimists who are
not panicked not necessarily paranoid
but they are
very interested and excited and feel
some moral obligation to focus on
solving really high leverage problems or
creating new technologies
I also see techno optimists like well if
a b and c gets bad enough if the
temperature of the earth gets to X Y and
Z then we'll have these Technologies and
all be fine and if this happens then
that'll all be fine and you know people
thought oil was going to run out by this
year but they didn't factor in that as
the number of barrels per year produced
went down the price would go up and then
all these other Technologies like
fracking became viable and voila no
problem I view those camps as somewhat
different and I'm just wondering if you
have any perspectives on that I love
your distinction between passive
optimism and active I think that's
brilliant and right on and but the
reality is is that you can't be active
about everything you have to kind of
Select tone choose and so there is a
sense in which okay
there is a greater than zero chance that
the Earth could be impacted by an
asteroid right and it would be really
devastating among the most devastating
things that could ever happen to this
planet far beyond even my climate change
sure
it would definitely change the climate
exactly and very fast so it's really
good that there is now a group of people
who are thinking about that and there's
you know the b1612 foundation which is
just tracking all the asteroids what was
it called b1612 after The Little Prince
okay right got it and it's a viable
thing that they've been they've been
behind all the tracking of all the
asteroids and kind of upping that and
then you know recently we just actually
sent something that hit the asteroid and
deflected it so it's the first Cosmic
impact you really had you know in the
cosmos pretty wild the thing a bunch of
monkeys on spinning rocks exactly right
figured out how to deflect so it's good
that there is a small group of people
but we don't need to to have that be our
concern for making National policy every
year I mean we're not that probability
is so low sure that shouldn't really be
a factor in us making our decisions
about what we're going to do this year
so that's passive in that sense I mean
we I can be passive about because there
is another group of people that is
active and you know that a group is
active right so one of the major
things for me was the more I thought
about the future the more I became
interested in history and the more I
read history
the more the reality of progress
became and I think just acknowledging
the reality of progress would go a large
huge step in helping our optimism